c'mon elimination my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is both Eve and I
believe that US firms will solve all of
the we took off from the world so to
help you on here at your today we're to
talk about how you can figure out what
you using anymore
rule number four is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and I was always there
watching you hear something that's
really aggressive each of you please
leave it down below quotes around other
needs to be inspired like win a prize -
and I'm going to write it down much more
likely to stick for yourself describe to
us
[Music]
the point I want to share with you is
when I was growing up my dad took out
this poem and he translated it from Sun
script into English and it was a poem
from the Bengali poet Rabindranath
Tagore and allow me to share it with you
it simply said spring has passed summer
has gone and winter is here and the song
I'm meant to sing remains unsung for
I've spent my days stringing and I'm
stringing my instrument and my brother
and I used to look at it every morning
before we go out to school but I never
really understood it and so when I got a
little older I said dad you know that
poem you had on our refrigerator door
what was it all about
and my dad looked at me said he said
Robin that was a poem written by a man
whose heart was filled with the regret
over a life half lived
he said Robin that was a poem written by
a man who postponed his life he always
wanted to do something special he always
wanted to do important work he always
wanted to be loving in the world he
always wanted to be creative he always
wanted to see the world but it got busy
being busy are you being busy being busy
have you lost that connection to the
life you wanted to live when you were a
little kid are you so busy stringing
your instrument that the song that your
life was meant to sing has died or is
dormant within you and my challenge to
you is simply this to do whatever takes
before you sleep tonight to reconnect
with the best within you that you may
have lost because one of the things I've
noticed is this there are too many
amongst us walking the planet today who
are sort of in a waking sleep they have
lost a sense of who they truly are and
your life will never work if there's a
huge space between who you truly are
and the person you know you're meant to
be your life will never be flooded with
energy creativity productivity and
happiness if there is a large space
between your life right now and your
unlived life and my request and
encouragement and challenge to you is
truly that you make the
happen so that the person you are
starting tomorrow is more of who you
know you truly are it makes me think of
George Bernard Shaw he was asked on his
deathbed what would you do if you could
live your life over again and he replied
after a long pause I wish I could become
the person I know I was meant to be and
I suggest to you it's never too late for
you to become the person you've always
wanted to be
but don't postpone it for next year
don't postpone it for next month start
being that person that human being that
creative force that business builder
that mother or father that athlete that
humanitarian that force of good that you
have always wanted to be beginning right
now if you're familiar with my work you
know for the last 34 years I've been
just obsessed with wanting to know what
makes the difference and the quality
people's lives why is it so many people
are big dreams but such a small number
of people ever make those dreams a
reality and for those that do make it a
reality what is it get them not only to
follow through but then to enjoy what
they have I don't know if you've ever
had the experience of achieving
something that you've always wanted and
then afterwards thinking to yourself is
this all there is some of the worst
feelings the worst it's almost worse
than than failing because when you say
at least you know hair can still find a
way to make it happen but when you
succeed and you're not happy you're not
fulfilled then you got a real problem
there's two things that control
everything in your life every thought
every feeling every emotion every action
you have in your life what you're
wearing today whether you're going to
turn this off within a few minutes or
whether you're going to stick with me
here for two or three minutes it's all
controlled by two things your beliefs
and your values whatever you believe if
you think life is just a waste of time
doesn't matter what you do or you know
you're big-boned then obviously you're
not going to go for it you're not going
to try to lose weight you're not going
to go push for that next level of your
career or your finances or or your
relationship or anything else beliefs
control us but some of our values some
people you know value just kicking back
some people value making it happen some
people value their family the most some
people value love but you know the real
challenge is we have not using conflict
when you really want to make a
difference in the world or you really
want to do well for your family or you
really want to do well financially but
simultaneously you know you don't want
upset anybody you want to be totally
honest you want to make everybody happy
when we have conflicts between what we
want and what we think we can have or
you know you have a goal of what you
really want to make happen but then you
have this other belief inside that says
damn stuff never doesn't work those
inner conflicts are what keep people
from using all of their energy it's kind
of like taking two steps forward and
three steps back you know it used to be
people kind of ran on kind of seven-year
cycles it's kind of an arbitrary number
but think about it from 17 to 24 is kind
of a stage of life for a lot of people
from 24 really till about 3
that's another stage of life 32 to 39 or
40 years old in other states 42 47
another stage and those are random
numbers but what I mean is people can
have an idea but they think life's about
it's my kids it's building my business
it's making money it's god it's family
it's whatever it is and then they go for
it for a period of time three four or
five six seven years whatever maybe ten
but then there's a time in which people
begin to question they begin to look at
their life and the begin to say is this
really what I want could you found
yourself with that at any time and then
they do one of two things
they either recommit and they go for
another seven years and they take it to
another level or they make a strategic
decision that shifts the direction of
their life either way your decisions
control your destiny and if you don't
choose that's a choice as well some
people just kind of stay in the middle
of that lukewarm place not shirring what
not sure what they really want so
there's kind of off the cuff what I'm
really trying to say to you is maybe the
question asked is what I want my life to
be today and what am I really going what
is my destiny what's going to fill me up
what's going to give me the meaning for
my life that's going to give me joy in
my life not just achievement but real
enjoyment a sense of meaning and
aliveness seven billion plus people on
the planet you're different than every
single one of them there's a unique
aspect to your personality your style
your intentions your actions your habits
your beliefs who you are and the way
that you think is unique from everybody
else we can measure it by science we can
measure it by observation we can measure
just by simply asking people to basic
questions to discover it everyone's got
their own opinion everyone's got their
own worldview and because of that then
we have to ask well am i living my life
uniquely you know am i expressing who I
genuinely am or my expressions genuine
and authentic and spontaneous to Who I
am as a person or am i living asad you
know am I trying to be somebody else to
please somebody else to gain acceptance
or love over here or am I truly being
true to myself to
unique self to the inner side of who I
really am and what I want to show to the
world because a lot of people really you
know struggle with this and the reason
they start setting out to look for their
purpose in their life is one day they
woke up and they realize they're not
living their life they're living their
parents like that professors life their
teachers life they're they're living the
life that society or their culture or
their norms told them to live one day
they wake up say whoa
why have I conformed to the point where
I want to know who I am anymore
and they start this journey sometimes to
look for life's to purpose because
they're trying to find themselves
they're not looking for a big purpose
they're looking for themselves and
sometimes when we can tap back into that
uniqueness of who we are then the magic
of life comes alive again you know that
requires us to not only exude who we are
to the world but to genuinely express
who we are what we think what we desire
of life what we need how we truly feel
and think about the people in our lives
the things that we are doing with our
lives the places and directions we're
going we have to do that if we want to
sense that full uniqueness of ourselves
and often it is by suppressing ourselves
that we begin to suffer and we have to
again ask well then what is the point of
all this is it to live as a you know as
a carbon copy of everybody else or to
fully with full intention and aliveness
animate the best of who we are uniquely
I think that you being yourself is a
grand purpose a brain tattoo I love
sharing with my audiences is this one a
job is only just a job if you see it as
a job and so why would you lose the
opportunity to leverage what you do
every day to grow your happiness to grow
your energy to allow you to release more
your talents in the world to allow you
to help more people why would you miss
that opportunity by falling into the
trap of thinking this is my job I'm just
getting up in the morning working 9:00
to 5:00 going down to the coal mine
every day and you could say well Robin
this doesn't apply to me you know I just
have a ordinary job well I've got to
tell you I've met taxi drivers who feel
their work is incredibly meaningful I
mean I was at LaGuardia and I remember
you know being in a taxi cab and the man
had this white shirt and his cab was
perfection and I said you know your
attitude is great your passion is
awesome you your cab is perfect you've
got this fresh newspaper for me to read
what is your psychology that allows you
to do this and he said Robin this is not
a dirty job it's an important job I get
to make a difference I remember being
Johannesburg meeting the janitor in the
Johannesburg men's room or WC who worked
like he was the Elon Musk of what he did
because he worked like Pavarotti saying
and so my point is simply this it's
really your choice as to how you will
view the work you do every day and even
in the most quote-unquote ordinary of
work you can find gold and if you
connect with the gold you connect with
the meaning and if you connect with the
meaning you connect with your talents
then you connect with your talent you
connect with the best within you and if
you check with the best within you you
go to work every day
and you are this shining star of
world-class and you become the Picasso
of your industry and everything else
takes care of itself I just can't
explain to everybody like clear when you
figure out who you are and do all that
you win if you're great a painting pink
and hire a partner to be your
salesperson if so many at 20 years old
made me their business partner as a
painter they'd be the most famous
painter in the world yet most painters
want to be the salesmen and businessmen
and women as well as the painter and
there's a problem
85% of painting 90% of people that are
great a painting are artists and don't
have the DNA to sell and vice versa all
my sales for
and the business friends that want to
start all these businesses around
something creative I've got news for you
Joel you know you can be a great
salesman but your pottery sucks and so
that's that so like it's really that's a
very funny analogy for the following
figure out who you are don't apologize
for who you are and then become even
greater than you naturally are at what
you are that's the whole the whole game
is broken because everybody's too tied
up into other people's opinions I only
care about my opinion myself and I care
what my mom and wife and kids and the
world think just not as much as I care
about the way I think about myself and I
and that's it just that slight advantage
and I think most of you care more about
what other people think and what you
think about yourself and or you actually
don't feel good about yourself right the
thing that made me smile when you just
introduced me you said I'm one of the
most motivational people in the world ,
and everybody I know that madam said
he's the nicest guy there's no
comparison to the better feeling of
people that have actually gotten to know
me say that versus millions hundreds of
thousands tens of thousands thinking I'm
the coolest and and and that's it I mean
that's it and that's why and that's why
it's easy for me to feel good about
myself right and so I think a lot of
people need to start with themselves
maybe the reason they don't have more
confidence in themselves or care about
their opinion about themselves versus
others is because they know they're
doing things they don't like so they
need to work on that I get offered and
emailed 5,000 different requests for
podcasts and shows and what's what I
think my friend here on what's his name
Evan
buh buh let's send it in bow I'm sorry
Evan Carmichael introduce me to bow will
bows figure it out this time at the
asset and so if you want Kevin Hart or
the rock or or Beyonce or
rule or Richard Branson or Tony Hsieh or
Sheryl Sandberg on your podcast maybe
you should start the 122nd podcast and
then you got to be creative in trying to
figure out how do you get maybe you
create the one question video show that
well shows one question promise you a
lot of people that you want to guess if
they see in the headline I just need
four minutes of your time for the one
question show a lot more to say yes then
can you be on my podcast for now and
have how do you know when you are on the
right path you and what dream belongs to
you or what husband belongs to you or
what job belongs to you you know you're
on the right path here's your clue
you're not beat you're not put in a
position to betray yourself you don't
betray yourself anymore you don't
you're not put in a position where you
feel like you have to negotiate your
sense of integrity hmm which is an act
of betrayal your heart an active
betrayal mm-hmm you don't feel like you
have to compromise who you are it feels
right you can fully I got that it's like
if you're at a job you know you're
really gifted and talented people are
not paying you for what you value
yourself to be you come into work every
day feeling like I'm really not valued
I'm not being respected for what I do or
my boss is unkind or whatever the
situation might be there's an uneasy
ring with you that's right yeah and so
when you have more respect for yourself
put yourself in a position where you can
you know fill your sense of value or
worth right that turns around that's
right and that's how you know you know
you know because you don't feel like
this isn't costing me my power
this isn't costing me my psyche this
isn't costing me my soul this is really
this is costing me my sense of I don't
feel confused in some deep level
I'm not drained I can be tired after a
day's work but I'm
that's psychically drained where I feel
like I'm losing life and losing myself
and losing money but a lot I'll say I'm
losing my myself why because I'm I'm
betraying myself in some way what is the
difference because I have a lot of
married friends I've interviewed a lot
of people over the years who are married
and everybody talks about how difficult
I'll you know it's work or relationship
is were divorced or what is the
difference between betraying yourself
and compromising because that's what I
have to do to get along I'd say that a
compromise mmm-hmm compromise is when
you willingly willingly willingly
willingly and out of love say that's
alright a little this little that little
this little that but in a compromise
you don't go away feeling like I
betrayed myself I betrayed myself I've
allowed myself I've put poison in my
mouth here okay it goes back to exactly
what you said earlier that every choice
is either going to enhance your spirit
or it's going to drain your spirit you
have been compromised to the point where
you feel drained or depleted right then
you've betrayed yourself you have I mean
again I got and the numbers of times
someone will say to themselves I want to
get out of this circumstance but I'm too
afraid to take care of myself so I will
lie about how happy I am in this
marriage
I will I will put up a front I will lie
about this but they're betraying
everything that's in their heart to
betray everything when they say to me my
on the right path here's what's true
you're on your right path you're just
not managing it that well right now
you're never on the wrong now on the
wrong path you just not managing it well
you're making choices that are harming
you uh-huh and that's why it's hurting
right now you're making unwise choices
and your intuition is trying to tell me
the unwise choices
including the passage Iran right right
and the way you're managing the path you
run and it's harming you okay and when
your life path begins to harm you then
we have to sit back and say you've taken
a detour you know I just had an aha
listening to you I love it when that
happens to me I've often thought that
and it's because of your use of the word
betrayal I've often thought having
experienced being betrayed by a close
member my family years ago thinking you
that was the worst that there's no
nothing worse than being betrayed and
just hearing you talk about it today I
think there's nothing worse than
betraying yourself that the worst most
ultimate betrayal is the betrayal to
yourself you're right yeah
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what do you do to this
video what did you take from it you're
going to immunity applies because like
40 degrees is somehow please share
because there are comments below I'm
really excited to see what you have I
want to give a quick shout it just gets
prettier and stiff thank you so much
your finger up with my folks your one
board and doing some review on your
website as well as posting it to Twitter
thank you so much as a support base and
I'm really happy to join them
thank you guys so much watching Isis
even you know to get you to believe in
yourself and whatever your whatever it
is much love have an amazing day
I wake up every single morning with a
very clear sense of purpose it's to
inspire people to do what inspires them
so together we can change our world and
I have a very clear vision of the world
I want to live it I would like to live
in a world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired to go to work they feel safe
when they're there and they come home at
the end of the day fulfilled by the work
that they do and I've committed all of
my work and it doesn't matter what form
it takes or the speaking or writing or
teaching or advising or doesn't even
matter what form it takes in some way
shape or form to help advance that
vision and move closer and closer to it
all what do I do with my life question
implied that adulthood is this
monolithic creature that like you
acquire your job and your spouse and
then you just ride it out until times
winged chariot shows up I thought this
when I was younger too and it's not our
fault because how does every single
happily-ever-after movie and with
finding your one true love and kissing
them occasionally marrying them at the
very latest having a child with them 95%
of romantic stories end with partners
committing to each other because
everything after that is just the blank
terrifying morass of adulthood this
monotonous grind in which the only real
excitement in your life is occasionally
finding a truly ripe avocado at the
grocery store
no it's make I'm not going to lie to you
I get very excited when I find a truly
ripe avocado at the grocery store but
it's not the only excitement in my life
and let me submit that one of the
reasons you're so terrified about
figuring out what you're going to do
with your life is that you think you're
only going to be able to do one thing
like if someone told you that in four
years you were going to have to pick one
musical note to listen to for the rest
of your life you would spend a lot of
time being super anxious about which
note to pick and the various total
qualities of different notes but that's
not what life is like you will always be
figuring out what to do with your life
and you'll get to do lots of different
things and your decisions will be unmade
by circumstance like your wife's gets a
job in Kuala Lumpur you're staring at
the night sky one night and decide you
want to get a PhD and astrophysics or
your uncle dies and there's no one to
take over as junkyard or your little
brother starts a freaking video
conference just like your life now
adulthood will have all this tension
between idealism and practicality and
you'll have to balance competing desires
and you don't have to do just one thing
you can be an electrical engineer who
volunteers on archaeological digs
William Carlos Williams was both a poet
and a doctor Julia
I'll decide from being an extraordinary
chef was also a freakin spy for the
United States I mean Hank if you told my
college self that I'd one day be a
novelist with the side gig putting my
mustachioed face on the torsos of
strangers I would have been duly
surprised and you studied organic
fracking chemistry before writing songs
about Harry Potter so here's my advice
study broadly and without fear we're in
a language if you can because that will
make your life more interesting read a
little bit every day but most
importantly try to surround yourself
with people you like and make cool stuff
with them in the end at least in my
experience what you do isn't going to be
nearly as interesting or important as
who you do it with a lot of people ask
me how do I know what my true purpose is
the answer is the difference between a
career and a calling is the difference
between satisfaction and fulfillment it
is the difference between an interest
and a passion what is the difference
between an interest and a passion so
many people are interested in is
interested in that but see when you go
to marry somebody you don't get down on
one knee and say baby would you marry me
I am interested in you nut no you don't
do that unless you want to get smacked
in the face and then left you got to say
baby I'm passionate about you you
complete me I can actually live this
life without you without us together
that's operated from the heart
and if you don't operate from the heart
I can guarantee you'll live a life
climbing a ladder and if you get to the
top you will realize that it was lame
against the wrong wall they say never
become too good at something you hate or
they will make you do it for the rest of
your life so live ask yourself these
three questions
what are your natural talents what is
something you enjoy doing what is
something that you can't shut up about
you got to read write and talk about it
that's how you get closer and closer to
your mission or purpose in life still
confused okay so I believe that the best
teacher of how to live life is dead
legend has it and when we are on our
death beds we will be visited my ghost
these are the ghosts of our ideas dreams
abilities talents given to us my life
and if we never acted on that idea never
pursue that dream never worked on those
skills used or voice or wrote that book
then those ghosts will say we came to
you and only you could have given us
life but now we must die with you
forever so ask yourself this question my
friends engage this thought experiment
if you have one year to live 365 days
and whatever you chose to do you were
guaranteed to succeed that what would
you do
chances are that is what you should be
doing right now